[Music]
and in age were average comic-book
movies make tons of money and average
sequels rake in the dough theater nerds
finally get something average to blow
their wads on to the greatest showman
from the musical geniuses behind lala
land and dear Evan Hanson comes a film
full of pretty visuals and catchy hits
just begging for an overly sincere
YouTube cover video as you sing along to
nine teen friendly jams wrapped in a
story that will make you wonder when is
the next song start the bank they're
evicting us I'm still not here for the
talkie bits ah that's better me PT
Barnum the boy who grew from wishing he
owned his own top hat to the man who
owned all the top hats played by noted
top hat enthusiast Hugh Jackman Milou
ghen follow along on Petey's lifelong
dream to open a weird murder Museum but
when that doesn't pan out
he'll row with his backup plan a scam
freak show paid for by fraud that he
abandons his wife and kids for and
ditches the second he has a chance to
join high society cam great but after a
series of show-stopping musical numbers
this social-climbing conman will be met
with lifelong success and happiness
maybe you are fraud maybe it was just
about making a buck oh they're on to you
quick do a hat trick witness this
real-life Willy Wonka but instead of
selling kids candy he selling kids
tickets to laugh at the Oompa Loompas
where the tragedy of these people's
exploitation is brushed aside
laughing anyway kids might as well
to spend more time with to perfect
physical specimens feast your eyes on a
forbidden romance subplot where Zac
Efron is rich and white but zendaya is
poor and usually a body double and while
the circus performers have to live with
being literally beaten in the streets
Efron MPT will get way more sympathy for
having cool snobby parents have you no
shame
thank you for your eyes and who even
snobby are critics I never liked your
shirt
so march to the beat of your own drum
with this upbeat inspiring musical about
a really shady cruel historical figure
but since too much honesty doesn't sell
we've got you covered with a more
accurate PT Barnum musical with songs
like the he wasn't a good guy saw
[Music]
like you
the made-up affair saw
[Music]
the these two people didn't even exist
song
[Music]
and the rampant cruelty saw
that's BT
[Music]
story huge as hands
young man Logan a disapproving wife
character a disapproving critic
character old School Musical
can she swing from a thread take a look
overhead lip-syncing possible and hairy
Elsa jerk du Soleil laugh while you can
Barnum an elephant never forgets hey
screen junkies this month we are proud
to partner with women and Phil to raise
funds and awareness for advancing the
careers of women in the entertainment
industry and on May 3rd we're putting on
the biggest movie fights extravaganza in
history to celebrate the show will be
driven by door donations so click the
box on the left or the link in the
description below to find out more we
want this to be the most epic movie
fights event of all time but we can't do
it without your help
the more you donate the more epic the
show becomes help us raise money for a
great cause and build a movie fight to
remember click the link now to donate
and learn more